one of the oldest and most influential
mega corporations
in the world of cyberpunk is arasaka it
has played a pivotal part in some of the
franchise's most
important stories and is set to be a
major player in cyberpunk 2077.
in many ways it's looking like arasaka's
role in the game is said to be the
culmination of
characters and plotlines the pen and
paper game has been building for decades
so before we see it play out in the
video game you need to know the history
of arasaka
who its major players are and how the
simple manufacturing company became a
trojan horse
for world domination
[Music]
the now monolithic arasaka started out
as a simple japanese manufacturing
company
it was founded around the turn of the
20th century by sasai arasaka
a clever businessman with a talent for
predicting the direction the world was
going
he saw world war ii on the horizon and
positioned his company as a major
military manufacturer for japan
bringing him a lot of success sasai also
had the foresight to see that japan
would lose
so arasaka began distributing its vast
wealth to overseas accounts
sparing itself from the ruin of the
japanese economy following the country's
surrender
in the years following the war arasaka
would slowly trickle those funds back
in keeping the company on top as a vital
part of japan
that's how arasaka got its start but the
history of the modern day arasaka begins
with sasai's son
saburo saburo arasaka was a renowned
pilot during world war
ii he was fiercely nationalistic
strongly believing that japan should
take its rightful place as leader of the
world
japan's surrender at the end of world
war ii was a huge blow for saburo
who contemplated suicide but like his
father he had the vision and foresight
to think ahead
saburo saw the global economic path the
world was taking
and knew that while japan had failed
militarily it could succeed commercially
thanks to his father's actions arasaka
continued to thrive
and accrue a massive fortune after the
war so saburo prepared and waited until
his father's death in 1960
when he assumed control of arasaka it
was then time for saburo to start the
long game
his end goal to bring back japan to
imperial glory
and become a political and economic
superpower that controlled the world
saburo's first step was to create and
expand the arasaka bank
the bank acted as the reliable backbone
of the company
always providing good income thanks to
smart business decisions on saburo's end
this allowed arasaka the freedom to
invest in other ventures
such as the arasaka security division
which provided the highest standards of
electronic security
as well as physical manpower like armed
guards by the 1990s arasaka security was
the most powerful
and respected security company in the
world with thousands of businesses using
their services
and then the collapse happened ever the
forward thinker
saburo saw the economic crash coming and
made preparations as well as a few
manipulations
in order to profit from the destruction
of modern society
arasaka came out of the collapse as one
of the largest corporations in the world
and it was time for saburo's master plan
to take shape
arasaka's security would create one of
the first corporate armies
saburo would go on a spree buying out
valuable businesses with arasaka bank in
one hand
and eviscerating the competition with
his personal army with the other
by 2020 the mantle of ceo pastor
saburo's eldest son
k arasaka but in many ways k was just a
figurehead and the true power in
decision making
still lay with a 101 year old saburo his
mind was still as sharp as ever and his
goal of complete world domination was
ever present
the only thing keeping him from
achieving it was alliances made by other
corporations
in the interest of keeping arasaka in
check one such corporation was
militech an american arms manufacturer
and military contractor
militech was arasaka's biggest
competitor and this rivalry would end up
being the source
of arasaka's first major defeat
what would later be known as the fourth
corporate war started in 2021
as a simple rivalry between ceno and
otec which were fighting over the assets
of the recently bankrupt ihak
looking to gain the upper hand both
turned to the backing of large megacorps
for military resources
otech went with militech and ceno went
with arasaka
the two megacorps had been at each
other's throats for years
and this was the perfect excuse they had
been looking for to begin a proxy war
where they could battle it out
unlike many proxy wars it stopped being
about a dispute over a bankrupt
company's assets
in fact by 2022 ceno and otec had
settled their little war
but arasaka and militech were just
getting started and tensions quickly
escalated into a very
real war many organizations and
countries around the globe were dragged
into their conflict
including the united states and japan
both of whose economies heavily relied
on militech and arasaka respectively
things were spiraling out of control
quickly as this corporate rivalry was
setting the world on fire
eventually arasaka began losing ground
in the united states
with its final major holdout being night
city home of its american headquarters
this all led to one of the most
important moments in the world of
cyberpunk
militech sent several strike teams of
mercenaries to infiltrate arasaka tower
one of which was led by the legendary
johnny silverhand
you can learn more about why johnny was
involved in our video about him
there's a lot that happened in arasaka
tower that day enough to do a whole
video on it alone
but the most important thing is how it
ended
a thermonuclear device was detonated
resulting in the destruction of central
night city
and the deaths of over half a million
people in what would later be referred
to as the night city holocaust
the blame was placed on arasaka and u.s
president elizabeth cress used the event
to nationalize militech
and expel arasaka from the united states
small conflicts continued for two more
years
but at this point arasaka had lost ceo k
arasaka eldest son of saburo died by
suicide in 2025
officially bringing the fourth corporate
war to an end
the fallout of the war severely damaged
arasaka
all its overseas assets had been seized
by different governments
and it was kicked out of pretty much
everywhere the japanese government which
had long butted heads with arasaka
was terrified of a potential retaliation
from other nations
despite not being directly involved but
the government still needed arasaka due
to its massive influence on the japanese
economy
so the government nationalized all of
arasaka's assets
and arasaka became a japan-only company
for the next decade with the loss of its
ceo and power
an internal power struggle took place
within arasaka
there are three major players the first
was the kiji
led by hanako arasaka the youngest
daughter of saburo
hanako is an intelligent and
kind-hearted woman who wanted to live an
independent life rather than be a porn
in her father's corporate game
which is perhaps why she led a faction
to grab the power for herself
next there's the hatto led by mishiko
arasaka the youngest daughter of the
late k
she is a u.s citizen and had the backing
of the us government
which wanted to take control of arasaka
the final group is the outside rebel
faction taka
led by yorinobu arasaka another of
saburo's children
yoronobu is by far the most interesting
of the three
when his father told him of the true
purpose of the arasaka corporation
yuronobu left his family in disgust he
went on to become a famous rocker boy
the johnny silverhand of japan more so
in the rebellious spirit as he was not
an actual musician
he started to steal dragons a gang he
used to attack arasaka from the shadows
yorenobu was even involved in the events
leading up to the nuclear destination of
arasaka tower
unfortunately there's not much
information on the details of this
decade-long family rivalry
however the conflict was eventually
solved and arasaka reunited under one
banner again
arasaka spent much of the next several
decades rebuilding power and regaining a
foothold outside of japan
a return to america was tricky following
its expulsion in 2023
but an opportunity presented itself for
arasaka to worm its way back in
the new united states had what was known
as the unification war in 2069
an attempt by the government to regain
control of a series of free states
that had seceded from the nation night
city had long been wary of the us
after it basically abandoned the city
following the night city holocaust
the city avoided involvement in the war
until the federal invasion of coronado
bay
gave them no choice but to act city
councilman lucius ryan turned to arasaka
for help
this was the opportunity arasaka was
looking for and it showed up
days later with the super carrier
causing a swift retreat
of the nusa the sudden involvement of
arasaka drummed up fears of another
fourth corporate war level crisis
and as such the new united states backed
down and signed a treaty of unification
ending the short-lived war night city
was now an independent city-state
and by the present day of 2077 arasaka
was once again
in control of the city which brings us
to the upcoming video
game in which arasaka plays a pretty
major role
if you pick the corporal life path
option main character v will start as an
employee for arasaka's counter
intelligence division
and you'll get to see the ruthless
arasaka corporate lifestyle for yourself
the company is also involved in the
game's main plot
which involves stealing an ancient
prototype chip from arasaka
expect an appearance from saburo arasaka
himself
who is still ceo of the company at the
ripe old age of 158.
how could he possibly still be alive you
ask well let's just say saburo had plans
long ago to download his personality
into an ai when he died
the very existence of this piece of tech
has been at the heart of many of
cyberpunk's most important stories
and will be an important part of the
video game yorinobu will also play a
role in the story
he has for unknown reasons returned to
the fold of his father's empire
but knowing him he has his own plans and
motivations
the events of cyberpunk 2077 might end
up being another major chapter
in the history of arasaka we covered a
lot of information today and there are
plenty of details left for further
exploration
in fact next week jake will be diving
deeper into the fourth corporate war
so make sure to come back for that as
always let us know if there's a
particular subject in the world of
cyberpunk you want to know more about
and thanks for watching
[Music]
you